ned ryan is the ceo of american majority
and he joins us ned great to see you
tonight thank you for being with us
um
sadly i think we have to ask the
question that's probably atop everyone's
mind it's bad but how bad can it get
oh i i don't think we're anywhere near
the bottom sadly will i you when you
hear biden saying that his solution to
solving inflation is more government
spending more regulation i mean these
are these will be jet fuel
on inflation and continue to tank the uh
economy and so when people hear these as
the solutions that's why he's he's he's
going down with hispanics independence i
would also point out will that that he's
at 57 approval in the black community
and to give people perspective right
before democrats got completely
shellacked in the 2010 midterms obama
was still over 90 with the black
community this thing is absolutely
trending in the wrong direction
and and the thing that i want to point
out to people though is this will
these these are not bugs these are
features of the biden administration the
outrageous government spending the
terrible energy policy all of these
things are absolutely intentional it's
not as though they're gonna wake up
someday and go oh yeah we made mistakes
we're gonna we're gonna solve this these
are intentional and they're doing it in
such a way to compel certain behavior
when i hear people talk about six
dollars for a gallon of gas i know many
on the left would prefer to have ten
dollars for a gallon of gas to compel
people to actually start using
renewables to force that behavior on
people and we're ruled by dangerous
fool's will they do not care about the
priorities of the american people they
do not care about anything that will
actually benefit the american people
because quite frankly in their arrogance
they don't think the dirty little
peasants know what's best for them but
ned you would think that they do care
about winning you know all of this
they're putting in place and what you
suggested is that it's a feature not a
bug would seem to get in the way of
winning an election in the midterms or
in 2024 where is their sense of
victory where is their sense of a
self-correcting mechanism ned
i i think they are so far gone i mean
they're stuck between a rock and a hard
place will in which the far left has
really taken over the democratic party
and and they really can't pivot out of
this and i think they're going to face
some really harsh realities in this
fall's midterms i i think biden will be
the 800 pound gorilla with cement boots
on democrats at the federal state and
local level and i think the interesting
thing about this will because they are
in denial i think that the devastating
absolute annihilation they will face in
2022 will have long-term benefits for
multiple election cycles 2024 and beyond
remember that old starting out live skit
ned with will ferrell where they play
give me more cowbell he's got
christopher walken in it as well and
it's don't fear the reaper no matter
what he wants more cowbell my suspicion
is that the answer to this will be more
cow bill it will be more democratic
accusations of them being the savior
from white supremacy and more
accusations of their opponent as racists
and let's see if that delivers them the
american people who are suffering from
this economy more cowbell ned we'll see
i i enjoy talking to you that's exactly
right yeah
thanks will hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else